cardetti bonsoir je autre chemise elle
fait un petit oui mais c'est parce que
je voulais pas mettre ça comme vous mon
cher hardy cela que je suis habillé en
noir qu'à moi alors si vous laissez pas
grave voilà bien pourquoi on noircit moi
je vous dirai pourquoi
pour les mêmes raisons non pas pour pas
montré que de temps en temps je prends
du bide
voilà pour moi aussi moi c'est pour être
sûres comme reconnaissent aussi ce que
vous n'êtes pas or de prendre le chichi
ça peut m'arriver ce qu'on vous voit par
donc vous triomphez dans un bel
enchaînement vous triomphez dans on
connaît la chanson on va pas en parler
le film le film triompher vous aussi
vous venez de tourner hasards et
coïncidences avec lelouch
mais je ne sais quoi l'histoire en deux
mots des gangsters des avocats n'ont pas
de dents que terre par l'avocat une
femme trois hommes y ont traversé la vie
de cette famille ont chacun leur
importance et puis et puis voilà et puis
à partir de là le hasard les
coïncidences qui n'existe pas comme tout
le monde le sait feront ce qu'ils ont à
faire
alors vous êtes sur le comte de monte
cristo fait quel rôle je fais le
procureur de villefort qui est donc cet
horrible personnage qui envoie deux
montes aubagne demandant thèse bien se
venger vingt ans plus tard d'une manière
terrible très beau personnage très noir
très terrible mais pareil que j'arrive
même affaire que finalement on a de la
compassion la fin pour ce personnage
tellement il souffre alors et vous êtes
à partir du 16 janvier dans le mari la
femme et l'amant donc de sacha guitry
que vous avez déjà joué un petit peu en
province et en suisse en belgique il a
créé à lyon 4 des célestins et puis on
l'étalé à marseille on est allé
à bruxelles on étale en suisse alors
quelques villes françaises et puis
maintenant on vient de jouer à paris
alors je n'ai pas vu la pièce
j'irai là bas sinon je préfère vous le
dire raison de plus pour me pour me la
vendre il ya un guitry revival en ce
moment dans toscan du plantier produit
des films tirés de wii fit wii et vous
pensez que c'est dû à c'est dû à quoi je
pense simplement que c'est dû au talent
de guitry qui comme toujours dans ces
cas là que ce soit guy trilles bernstein
par exemple quand rennes a remis
bernstein au goût du jour il n'avait
plus avec mélo vous savez dans ces
cas-là ce genre d'auteurs qui ont été
des auteurs à grand succès des auteurs
très publique et des auteurs qu'on a
qualifié ou de pompiers ou de
boulevardier qui aura été et est auteur
bien plus intéressant que ça on était
foutu à la poubelle par une intelligente
un circuit comme d'habitude à tourner un
peu vite de 1 ce qui écrivait ces gens
là et on se découvre aujourd'hui que
évidemment ces gens là ont des choses à
dire qu'elles soient légères ou moins
légère
en tout cas il est 10e avec talent et
donc on re découvre avec plaisir ce
talent dans l'histoire c'est quoi
l'histoire ya pas l'histoire oui il ya
une morale immoral yako font la morale
immoral de guitry c'est que ladite
l'adultère est le premier sauveur du
couple et que si on veut faire un couple
qui se porte bien après il faut avoir un
amant dans la sphère sinon on s'ennuie
bon alors évidemment c'est à la fois
formidablement l'insolence et
délicieusement iconoclaste et en même
temps c'est une espèce de deux verres de
de santé et de bonheur délicieux vous
faites la main bah oui je fais l'amour
votre compagne evelyne bouix fait la faf
et la femme et le réalisateur par le
metteur en scène bernard murat
c'est le fait le mari oui et les bilans
c'est assez rigolo parce que vous êtes
l'amant de votre femme est mon meilleur
ami avec cette femme c'est le pnc très
geek rim en plus ce qui est drôle c'est
que vous vous dites souvent dans vos
interviews que vous essayez de vous
comporter avec une bimbo x un peu comme
un amant c'est vous donner des rendez
vous avez acheté un portable pour vous
téléphonez donc c'est assez rigolo
finalement non finalement le
la réalité plus forte que la fiction non
mais ce qui est ce qui est joli
dans cette histoire que c'est au fond
c'est une aventure de d'amis je suis
très depuis très longtemps ami avec
bernard murat je suis très longtemps
puisque ami avec evelyne bouix et le
fait de cette rencontre à 3 1 est une
sorte de retrouvailles et artistique et
sentimental et habiter en tout cas
tourné à vous devez être heureux tous
les trois la fusée manif un spectacle à
un succès énorme
donc j'espère qu'il va avoir le même
succès ici à paris les gens parlent un
plaisir délicieux ce qu'on imaginait
bien mais même très au delà de ce qu'on
avait pu imaginer car comme toujours on
est moins intelligent que l'auteur
intelligent l'auteur a écrit des choses
formidables qu'on n'avait même pas vu
aux répétitions et une coupe public lui
a valu immédiatement
donc ça c'est c'est délicieux edmonde
charles roux qui est venu voir le
spectacle à un marseille qui monte qui
l'adoré c'est alice formidable plus
aucun d'entre nous ne serait capable
d'écrire comme ça aujourd'hui et c'est
absolument vrai parce que c'est moi je
veux bien qu'on traite ça de boulevard
si on veut ça m'est complètement égal ou
table bourgeois d'une façon il n'ya que
du théâtre bourgeois john calame là pour
qui est peut-être bon jour pour faire la
révolution la fois l'été nous emmerder
avec cette terminologie là c'est un
théâtre en tout cas populaire et
sublimement écrit c'est une langue très
très peu de gens aujourd'hui serait
capable
on a tous envie de le voir je vous
rassure je trouve ça faire un tabac à
paris aussi c'est votre votre première
enfin ça pourrait faire vous êtes sur
scène avec une rixe j aime la deuxième
fois vous ai pas peur de terminer enfin
terminée c'est pas méchant mais un peu
comme renaud barrault ou avaler comment
simone valère et jean desailly ou the
stone et charden là tout le temps semble
d'abord stone charden de renaud barrault
desailly-valère wes a pas trop de
rapport
sinon us caire qu'il joue avait légiféré
reali bon écoutez c'est pas désagréable
non jeu pas comme ça dans la journée
qu'une personne non parce que si vous
voulez on est toute la journée pour
faire autre chose ensemble pour faire
autre chose que pour payer des notes de
gaz pour caler au cabinet oui c'est vrai
donc on vit dans un univers et pas celui
de la réalité
un univers poétique donc je vois pas
comment on pourrait mieux partagé sa vie
que de cette manière là et puis ensuite
on est quand même loin du compte
renaud barrault ont passé 60 ans
ensemble et d'une manière admirable
j'espère que je passerai aussi longtemps
de ça avec avec avec evelyne mais enfin
on est quand même très autonome est pris
à l'étagé ce qu'on fait c'est pareil
c'est ce qu'on a longtemps vous habitiez
pas ensemble on a on l'a on s'est
apprivoisés mutuellement
voilà alors vous avez l'habitude dans
tous les cas souvent vous donnez votre
avis comme ça sur des sujets autres que
votre métier vous dites quand un artiste
parle de politique c'est possible ce qui
est déjà plus difficile c'est quand un
homme politique parle d'art donc vous
êtes souvent autorisés à vous exprimer
sur saint germain sujet je dis que c'est
moins grave pour un acteur de faire de
la politique que pour un homme politique
de jouer la comédie
on est écrit dans le monde un papier 395
en disant je demande à la gauche de
redevenir la gauche il grand papier
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui alors en
deux mots est ce que vous pensez que ça
va ou ne va pas je sais pas je pense que
en tout cas c'est sur la bonne voie je
vous attendais parce que vous disent le
contraire mais je ne suis pas du tout un
béni oui oui je veux dire que ce que
j'aime c'est jospin c'est qui fait pas
de la communication mais il fait de la
politique qu'on voit peu dans les médias
on y travaille que les gens qui sont
autour de lui travaille également que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce qu'il dit
il le fait où il tente de le faire avec
bonne foi d'ailleurs majorité des gens
le reconnaissent
après on verra bien les résultats seront
là nous serons pas là on souhaite tous
qui seront là mais si vous voulez je
trouve que hilare toucher du doigt ce
que moi en tout cas
j'imaginais que de la gauche
c'est-à-dire hillary identifier le
discours de la gauche ça va les lois
pasqua les 35 heures oui on peut
discuter sur les lois pasqua c'est vrai
qu'on les approche pas en même temps
c'est plus compliqué que ça en a l'air
tout ça il ya je flâne et suit pas pour
le moment ça va je ne suis pas déçu je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin mais je
ne suis pas déçu je pense que cet homme
est un homme droit il ya une vraie
rectitude de penser et d'actes ça me va
parfaitement
alors vous êtes souvent au point des
positions disons un peu moraliste des
fois même de moralisateur est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas le sentiment je vais un
peu
l'agressivité à mais quand même des fois
dans son c'est un peu des portes
ouvertes celles que vous dites par
exemple mois la valeur numéro un pour
moi c'est la tolérance qui oserait dire
le contraire des tas de gens d'état tram
en mai de tout genre des tas de gens ne
le disent pas mais le fond oui si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je verrais
bien un endroit où la tolérance est un
aveu pu être largement disparu de la
circulation il ya des tas de gens pour
lesquels la tolérance n'est pas une
valeur fondamentale
il ya des tas de gens qui ne tolère pas
l'autre les autres ou ce que font les
autres
excusez moi ce que je veux dire c'est
pas l'impression de vous indigner
finalement sur des sujets où vous pouvez
demander à peu près d'accord non moi je
crois pas que tout le monde est à peu
près d'accord je suis pas pour les
consensus où je suis tout à fait prêt à
reconnaître à des gens qui ne sont pas
de mon bord que c'est eux qui commandent
horizon réseau contre ce que je peux
penser moi et dans ces cas là je suis le
premier à m'incliner je suis tout à fait
capable de changer d'avis quand l'autre
à raison face de moi même si je passe
mon bac je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui simplement votre compagne
evelyne bouix disait en parlant d'autre
attitude dans la vie elle disait
finalement pierre c'est un peu comme
condorcet jeu est ce que vous venez de
dire mais je me battrai à mort pour
jusqu'à la mort pour que vous puissiez
le dire et vous vous dites dans une
autre interview
la démocratie ne peut tolérer ce qui ne
la tolère pas ce qui revient à dire un
peu pas de liberté pour les ennemis de
la liberté
alors là justement nous y voilà enracine
peut tolérer que ce qu'il a tout l'air
d'un jeune en question est profondément
belle la démocratie et pelé peut tolérer
énormément de choses peut-être
énormément le show condorcet c'est à
dire je partage pas vous avez votre avis
mais je suis prêt à mourir pour puissiez
vous exprimer ou au contraire pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté
faut interdire le front national par
exemple puisque c'est un sujet qui
occupe beaucoup les débats en ce moment
écoutez je c'est vrai que si vous me
demandez de réagir comme ça
viscéralement
j'aurais bien envie de dire qu'après
tout il faut interdire le front national
finalement j'aurais tort de le dire
d'abord parce que ce parti et ceux qui
le dirigent s'appuie sur une situation
économique et sociale extrêmement
difficile qui est mondiale mais qui est
spécifiquement difficile en france et
que tous les gens qui votent pour le
front national ne sont pas des gens
forcément condamnable sont des gens en
perdition donc c'est d'ailleurs en cela
que donc on demande à la gauche d'être
de nouveau là gosset terre de régler ces
problèmes là on sait très bien
et si on tord le cou aux problèmes du
chômage le front national n'aura plus
rien sur quoi repose et donc
effectivement le problème n'est pas
d'interdire le front national le
problème est de tendre le cou aux
problèmes sur laquelle il s'appuie pour
dresser les gens les uns contre les
autres c'est à dire l'air la haine de
l'autre l'exclusion le le le bouc
émissaire de l'immigré ou de celui qui
n'est pas comme vous qui ne parlent pas
la même langue et qui voleraient
parait-il votre travail mais si on ne
rompt au foot est dehors tous les
immigrés de france mais l'économie
française ce serait ce serait un
véritable désastre parce que les
immigrés nous sommes en france qu'ils
consomment
non mais je j'y reviens donc par rapport
au front national par exemple donc l
attitude qui est l'attitude de dire je
partage pas vos idées mais vous pouvez
exprimer
ou alors je pas liberté vos ennemis de
la liberté vous êtes sur les partisans
que le front national puisse s'exprimer
normalement au contraire qu'ils
s'expriment plus que plus que librement
et quand il s'exprime on peut pas dire
qu'il le fasse dans la dentelle
alors il est inutile ou de vous dire que
moi personnellement je préférerais ne
pas entendre ce genre de propos mais en
même temps la diabolisation
c'est une chose qui finira par se
retourner contre les gens qui ne règle
pas les problèmes la seule manière de
faire taire ce discours c'est de régler
les problèmes de la nation c'était réglé
le problème numéro 1 en france qui n'est
pas le problème de l'immigration
mais problème du chômage est ce qu'il
est réglable vous demander ça à moi si
ça va vous trouver les jeunes arrageois
lionel jospin des gens du gouvernement
maintenant j'ai une bonne solution au
problème je dire qu' en france vous
savez très bien en allemagne c'est parti
c'est probablement extrêmement complexe
la question qu'on peut se poser que
viviane forrester le pose dans son livre
très controversé comprend pourquoi il
est très controversé parce que ce livre
vu des choses terribles c'est que
peut-être aujourd'hui il ya toute une
catégorie de gens dont on n'a plus
besoin et auxquels on n'ose pas dire
qu'on a plus besoin d'eux et ça c'est
une horreur alors on peut se poser la
question qu'est ce qu'on fait ces gens
là on les parque on aimait dans des
camps de concentration on les gaz angels
à l'époque contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire faire un parterre
détails qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces gens là
aujourd'hui il occupe des assedic parce
qu'ils en ont marre de ne pas être
d'être coupable de ne pas travailler ils
veulent travailler ils ne peuvent pas
travailler
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait si on n'en fait
rien effectivement faut les payer
pour nous il était bien raisonnable je
conçois pas qu'on les a occupés
il était lié nationaux et
des oeuvres aujourd'hui on arrive même
induire les occuper le problème est
extrêmement complexe est facile de dire
qu'on pourrait arriver ça comme ça comme
ça il ya kayak à ya sûrement pas qu'à
mai mais c'est le problème de fond au
dernier point quand ça vous touche
personnellement c'est à dire par exemple
un moment il ya eu un problème de texte
étranger au rond point des champs
elysées où vous avez déclaré ben moi je
suis contre le fait qu'on joue des
textes étrangers dans cet extrait vous
avez dit à ce moment-là si c est tres
nos faibles alors je suis xénophobe
vous avez déclaré oui ça devait pas être
aussi simple que ça mais je vois à quoi
vous faites allusion
c'est à dire quand ça vous touche
finalement là là non c'est pas ça
non c'est pas ça c'est que simplement je
veux dire que à une certaine époque on a
transformé pour l'apa transformer on
appris le tape dur au point et on a
cueilli un certain nombre de troupes
étrangères qu'on a parfaitement bien
fait d'accueillir pour seulement il y
avait déjà le théâtre de l'europe
alors peut-être aurait-on pu comment
dire prolonger l'héritage barreau
renault dans une digne comme celle-là
crée aussi un certain nombre d'auteurs
français contemporains vivants pour
jouent peu ou pas du tout bon et puis il
ya d'autres théâtres
encore une fois comme l'odéon par
exemple où elles sont de grands centres
dont c'est la vocation d'un qu'obligé de
2,2 de prendre les salles des faits
derrière les autres pour ne pas non plus
créer des auteurs français n'y a pas de
xénophobie du tout là dedans je suis
l'honneur l'honneur de la france est
d'accueillir les cultures du monde
entier
la france est probalement le pays qui en
a que de plus c'est clair et net
elle accueille des cultures du monde
entier que ce soit le cinéma le théâtre
la mode la peinture le les arts de la
table ce que vous voulez le pari est la
seule ville et la france est le seul
pays au monde
vous pouvez voir de la culture du monde
entier le sol même en amérique nord
l'angleterre ça n'existe pas ça donc je
suis violemment pour ouvrir fera je veux
simplement vous expliquer sur cette
phrase je m'explique je m'explique
d'autant plus
facilement qu'à l'époque on nous a fait
comprendre je ne suis pas le seul à
m'être exprimée et probablement pas
cette manière là je me souviens de
suzanne flon francine bergé parce qu'on
nous a expliqué qu'on est et xénophobes
et qu'après tout alors mais aussi on
appellera loin des thèses du front
national soit qu'on a répondu qu'on
était les programmes en avoir créé des
auteurs étrangers
d'accord je vous remercie beaucoup donc
je rappelle le titre de votre pièce
c'est le mari la femme et l'amant de
sacha guitry au théâtre des variétés à
partir du 16 janvier merci beaucoup et
on sera là
bah oui qu'est ce que vous voulez venez
à plus les corrections de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou